whether you've owned a playstation or
not you'd probably be able to recognize
most of these accessories but what about
this little dude or
whatever this thing is there's a lot of
strange accessories for the playstation
you may know them forgotten about them
or didn't even know they existed
in the first place so today we're
looking back at some of the more
off beat ones first up the pocket
station
no it's not a tamagotchi but actually a
memory card
and a personal digital assistant for the
playstation 1 that also
added some on the go functionality with
select playstation games making this
sort of like
sony's first handheld console thing now
you may be like
dude so it's like the dreamcast memory
card in which you're exactly right man
six months before this was released the
sega dreamcast came out in japan
and one of its key and most interesting
features was
the visual memory unit the memory card
slash
second screen that went into its
controller the pocket station was
playstation's answer to sega's vmu
however
unlike the dreamcast it was only
released in japan
and wouldn't you know it it actually
outlived the dreamcast
by one year being discontinued in 2002
interestingly it was revived in an app
for the vita in 2013 but
again only in japan back in 2004
two years before the wii something else
beat nintendo to the motion control
revolution
horiz katana the soul controller
[Applause]
this was specifically bundled with
animusha 3 demon siege for the ps2
it was wireless and featured all the
buttons of a dual shock but
just bunched up and amoglimated onto the
katana's handle
and most importantly you could swing it
wildly to kill off demons
it was ergonomically questionable to say
the least
it was hori's first u.s product and
well they certainly chose one hell of an
item to break out into the western
market with maybe it didn't quite take
off the same way as the wii remote but
its legacy lives on to this day
through super lewis 64 who managed to
get it working with ghosts
of sushima next up the eye mode
did you know that playstation 1 had a
web browser through
a cell phone released only in japan the
whole thing was a partnership
between sony and docomo to grow the cell
phone's gamer base
using the cable you could play its games
through the console on your tv
and even surf the world wide web also
it actually worked with some playstation
games like dragon warrior monsters 1
and 2 allowing you to upload monsters
from the ps1 into the mobile version of
the game
or in weirder kind of fourth wall
breaking ways like
with the game one piece mansion where
you'd receive emails from characters
in the game i wish i worked with games
like jakey chance on master just so i
can get an email from him
saying happy birthday or dear curt let's
fight like gentlemen
love jackie ah yes the namco nebcon
racing controller
this was designed specifically to
emulate dual joystick controls of the
arcade game
cybersled when it was ported to the
playstation it's definitely confusing to
look at and understand at first but
despite its esoteric design
plenty of other racing games took
advantage of it like ridge racer
and gran turismo by rotating either side
it simulates a steering wheel turning
left and right
and strangely it doesn't feature the
usual symbol based cross
square circle and triangle buttons but
rather b
and a buttons the floppy disk memory
card reader
sometimes the standard playstation
memory cards just didn't have enough
space and in an era
prior to external hard drives some third
part companies had to get a little
innovative with game files like using
floppy disks with a daytel memory drive
now honestly this actually wasn't all
that bad of an idea floppy disks were
way cheaper than playstation licensed
memory cards at the time so
in theory this was a more affordable way
to go
i'll be at a less convenient one as it
also needed to be
plugged in so carrying that and some
floppy disks to a friend's house just to
show them you have dr
boscovinich unlocked in tekken3 would
have been kind of a chore
and well straight up super uncool
today the memory drive can be used for
200
as opposed to playstation memory cards
which are actually more affordable today
than
they were all those years ago so yeah
maybe in
hindsight uh this didn't make that much
sense
[Music]
there we have it now with the
playstation 5's left field design
here's to hoping that it'll influence
some strange and unusual accessories as
well because
weird is good stay weird also while
making this episode
i learned that there's a lot of let's
say fascinating controllers out there
for the playstation so be on the lookout
for video
all about that in the coming weeks
anyways i'm current davina
until next time see ya
[Music]
you